I've recently released a video with Greg
McEwan who wrote the book essentialism
and he talks it about what's that really
good amazing yeah and his kinda is more
of a is very similar and for a lot of
people could be the same exact thing as
minimalism I think he focuses much less
on the stuff and the things in our lives
and just goes to how yeah how we make
our decisions and how are we spending
our time and our energy which I think is
the eventual point of minimalism but he
talks about the paradox of success is
that when you get more success it's not
always a good thing because then you
have a lot more opportunities in the
beginning you have to say yes to as much
as you can and I know you guys have
talked about this quite a bit yeah to
the point where you can then start to
say no but then if you continue to have
that mindset I'm always going to say yes
every opportunity that comes in then
you're very likely not going to have the
time that you originally had to make the
work that made you successful or that
got you to that place that you currently
are yeah it's I don't know when that
tipping point is but yeah there
definitely is a point where it's like
you have to start saying no a lot more
than what you say yes you know yeah
sorry I have a question like how do you
guys this is something that I'm
struggling with now because I do get a
lot of requests for people hey coffee or
you want to do this can I come on your
podcast how have you guys found it
tactfully say no to people well we set
the expectation up like on our website
like as soon as I get someone's like hey
I have a sa I'd like to share in your
your your blog I'm like well then you
don't read our blog because we don't we
don't take guest essays so like I just
ignore emails like that but but you can
set up the expectation whether it's on
your YouTube page or in wherever your
profiles are that sets the expectation
of like if you you know if you want to
have an interview with me like a email
this email address like we have a lot of
media requests we have someone to handle
that for us and then they get to say no
the same thing with speaking gigs too
it's like we have Andrew who like he
gets to be the the guy who says no it's
not us having to say no anymore
what if it's somebody that's kind of
within the circle they're maybe a friend
of a friend
maybe somebody that you feel like oh I
kind of
should because I know this person that
knows this person I attack for well give
you a specific example but I mean the
pithy answer that I often use is like
say yes until you have to say no and
then say no until you have to say yes
and that's exactly we're talking about
earlier like early on it's like yeah say
yes to every project free projects you
get your build your portfolio connect
with people network until you get those
successes that's important right but now
what you're saying is you're at this
point where it's time so saying nones
you have to say yes or do you get to say
yes like the Gary Vee thing is like
something you get to say yes to right
you did the interview with with him and
put that all on on your channel now you
get to say yes to to these things but
you sent me a friend of a friend who has
chemical sensitivities and and he was
trying to like find an apartment and
I've had a bunch of health issues
recently and I just haven't had the
bandwidth and I just had to be honest so
for me the the way that I addressed this
a lot is I don't have the bandwidth to
do this thank you for understanding
and that that is the other key is like
saying no in a way that helps people
understand so you're saying no but
you're you are letting them know very
clearly what you're saying yes to the
problem that I have is that when I say
no I always say but maybe in a couple
months
reach out in a couple months and then
they always reach out is that true
though
like maybe feel like you know makes me
feel good but also I know whenever it
always comes I'm always always still
don't want to do this yeah
you